-There are busy things going on.
Sometimes -- and, look,
I think people should --
If people want to play tennis,
they should be able
to play tennis.
I feel very strongly about this.
But on I guess it was Thursday
of last week, our First Lady
in the middle of a pandemic,
posted a photo about how
the tennis pavilion is going
As someone
who was in communications,
do you think this is a good time
to give the people of Americ
an update on the pavilion?
[ Laughter ]
-Uh, let me see. No.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, are you --
Are you kind of shock-proo
at this point
when you see something?
-No, no.
I keep waiting for that.
Like, every morning, I wake up
we're getting older,
so I feel achy.
And then, I'm like, "Am I past
the point where he can gall me?"
-Yeah.
-And I never am.
I turn on "Morning Joe,"
and I'm shouting at the TV
like a lunatic.
And if I didn't have my show
I would be that person
yelling the news --
-It's nice, yeah.
When I have --
when I have a hiatus,
I just mutter to myself.
It's very helpful.
-I do, I do!
I'm the one in the dog park,
yelling, like,
"You know,
Pence isn't any better!"
And they're like...
[ Laughter ]
-"Lady, come on!
Also, you need a dog
to be here."
[ Laughter ]
You -- You get to cover --
So we have another night
of primaries tomorrow.
How have you found --
Because those are long nights.
I think we have six.
Is it six tomorrow?
-Oh, don't tell me.
They didn't tell me.
-Yeah.
-Yes, there's six contests
-Six contests.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-How have you found
getting through the primary?
Have you changed the way
you go about it?
-Well, so,
I slid from impeachment,
which was, you know, six t
eight hours of covering that
right into the --
they didn't tell me.
One day, it was impeachment,
and, "Oh, you have to stay late.
We've gotta --"
So we eased right into that.
Rachel Maddow said to me
last week, you know,
"I've noticed in all these
nights that everything you eat
is in pellet form."
It's like a kibble.
It's either a Skittle
or a seed or...
-Yeah.
-I don't eat anything...
So, you know,
the greatest impact is probabl
on the lack
of a well-rounded diet.
But what an exciting election.
I mean, this has not been what
anyone thought it would be
-No. It's --
I mean, heaven forbid,
we should have anything that
goes the way we wanted or --
[ Laughter ]
Or, not the way we wanted.
The way you think it's gonna go.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You know it is --
-Predictions are dead.
-Just one thing. Yeah.
Predictions are dead all over.
-Predictions are dead.
-Your first communications job
was for the Oakland A's.
-Yes.
-And yet, coming into this job
you did not --
you were not a baseball fan?
-My job with the Oakland A's
-Yeah.
-Well, I just wasn't
a baseball expert.
-Gotcha.
-And so, this is part of
my sort of life
as the Forrest Gump of P.R
I ended up
helping the Oakland A's.
It was my first job
out of college.
And it was the year
of the players' strike.
And so, I was -- it's mayb
where I first got to practice,
you know, the art of spin.
-Yeah.
-I was writing press release
about the replacement player
and how great they were.
They were gonna be just as goo
as the regular players.
And this might be how I ended up
spinning for Republicans.
They're just as good
as the other guys.
[ Laughter ]
But it wasn't -- you know --
I mean, that's another --
it's so funny,
the volume of news
in every corner.
You know, baseball's had
a big -- a big year, too.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes. There are times
that I think, "Certain peopl
working for certain teams
right now would be like,
'Man, what I wouldn't give
for a job in the White House.'
[ Laughter ]
"'Seems like these things
are calm.'"
-They should collaborate, right?
-Yeah, they should collaborate
Hey, thanks so much
for being here.